il y règne un calme inhabituel à
roberval normalement la ville serait
plongé dans les préparatifs des
différentes compétitions nages et du
fameux souper dans les rues
c'est très simple on a besoin de
beaucoup de monde dans les rues dans les
centres d'achats dans les campings sont
des pareils ça faisait un engouement
petit ça nous met en valeur roberval
aussi certain que ça nous fait un petit
quelque chose sur lequel le dommage mais
on va s'occuper à autre chose la ville a
quand même fait un effort pour qu'il y
ait un peu d'animation au centre ville
une partie du boulevard saint joseph a
été fermée à la circulation pour y
aménager une terrasse urbaine est un jeu
d'évasion 100% de l'argent des
inscriptions et même des donations parce
qu'il ya des gens qui font des donations
va à la saint-vincent-de-paul du secteur
roberval sa mise de centre les gens
s'approprient leur milieu de vie des
spectacles ambulants et différentes
activités sont prévues et pour remplacer
le souper dans les rues on propose je
subis dans la rue on invite les citoyens
à aménager une table dans l'entrée de
leur résidence et y inviter des convives
culturellement c'est dans le cadre des
robervalois puis ça demande moins gros
efforts on est en pleine période des
vacances de construction fait le fond de
l'inviter les gens passaient dans la rue
chez nous avec quelques amis ces jeux se
sera pas pareil mais si si j'ai des amis
qui sont pris aux mains de la famille un
peu loupé souvenant ferreux côté
natation on a même pensé organiser une
compétition de nage à l'échelle locale
mais les contraintes étaient trop
nombreuses
malheureusement et qui dit faux là
l'arrivée difficulté de respecter la
distanciation sociale puis c'est bien
important pour nous de respecter les
règles du gouvernement du québec mais un
client que d'entraînement qui servait
normalement aux athlètes est disponible
pour les gens qui veulent tenter
l'expérience de la nage dans le lac
saint jean ça fonctionne je vous dirais
que pas mal du monde à tous les soirs
qui viennent s'entraîner dans l'après
midi arrive que conçoit dans les bureaux
et qu'on voit certains nageurs donc que
oui je vous dirais que c'est assez
populaire bien entendu toutes ces
initiatives ne compenseront pas
totalement pour des retombées engendrées
par la traversée internationale du lac
saint-jean cependant le milieu ainsi se
dit surpris de constater qu'il ya
plusieurs touristes actuellement de
l'extérieur de la région qui sont dans
ce secteur de roberval ce qui se dira
plusieurs que la catastrophe anticipée
d'un secteur touristique n'aura
peut-être pas lieu finale
avec val jalbert avec le zoo roberval
est situé en plein en plein centre entre
les deux au niveau des au niveau des
entreprises hébergement
les hôtels et motels nous disent que
l'achalandage est très fort pour la
traversée c'est aussi l'occasion de
faire peau neuve et de rafraîchir ses
installations on trouve un peu que nos
chaloupe manque un peu de peinture donc
28 chaloupe même sens a traversé le lac
saint jean à lui seul peut justifier le
déplacement ici louis martineau radio
canada roberval